und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend die amerikaner haben heute
geliefert bekommen was sie auf den
ersten blick am allerwenigsten brauchen
nämlich noch einen demokratischen
bewerber um die heldenrolle im wahljahr
2020 die aufgabe
donald trump herauszufordern dabei ist
die schar der herausforderer schon jetzt
für normalverbraucher viel zu
unübersichtlich und die richtung in die
es gehen soll unklar
was wollen sie denn machen nach links
außen gehen eine ganz radikale
alternative zu trump die kandidaten
dafür gibt es schon mehrfach oder mit
einem alten hasen wie joe biden schön in
der mitte bleiben
bisher ist jemand nicht dabei den donald
trump fürchten muss
der späte neuzugang heute michael
bloomberg hat da ein etwas anderes
kaliber ist zig mal reicher als tramp er
wurde dreimal gewählt als bürgermeister
von new york
und wer ist dort schafft heißt es ja
schafft es überall
michael bloomberg kommt aus der
mittelklasse hat sich hochgearbeitet ist
zum milliardär geworden
in seinem wahlkampf video erzählt der
neue im kandidatenfeld aus seinem leben
amerikaner lieben solche
erfolgsgeschichten der werbeclip kommt
zeitgleich mit seiner offiziellen
kandidatur und einer kampfansage gegen
den aktuellen us präsidenten
ich kandidiere für die präsidentschaft
und donald trump zu besiegen und amerika
wieder aufzubauen
in den vergangenen tagen hatte sich
michael bloomberg bereits in mehreren
bundesstaaten für eine teilnahme an den
vorwahlen angemeldet in arkansas gab er
sich volksnah
der multimilliardär im diner ich kämpfe
für euch seine botschaft blumberg reiht
sich spät ein in ein übervolles
bewerberfeld der demokraten der 77
jährige ex bürgermeister von new york
tritt mit einer liberalen agenda an und
mit 52 milliarden dollar im rücken kaum
kandidat hat er für seine tv werbung
bereits mit einem schlag mehr ausgegeben
als fast alle anderen demokratischen
bewerber
wahlen sollten nicht zum verkauf stehen
nicht für milliardäre nicht für
unternehmensvorstände wir müssen eine
graswurzelbewegung aufbauen so
funktioniert demokratie
keinen der bisherigen kandidaten scheint
bloomberg einen sieg gegen den
us-präsidenten zuzutrauen
blumberg verachtet donald trump machte
daraus auch 2016 auf dem parteitag der
demokraten kein geheimnis ich bin ein
new yorker und ich erkenne einen
betrüger wenn ich einen sehr
der präsident glaubte schon vor ein paar
tagen als sich bloombergs kandidatur
abzeichnete er hat nicht den zauber um
erfolgreich zu sein der kleine michael
wird versagen es gibt niemanden gegen
den ich lieber antreten würde
als gegen den kleinen michael doch der
kleine michael hat ein großes vermögen
ein weit größeres als doppeltop mit dem
und seiner liberalen politik will er im
kampf ums weiße haus einen anderen
gefährlich werden
ein bisschen überraschung ist da schon
noch dritter im märz hat blumenberg doch
gesagt ich mache es nicht und jetzt mag
das doch warum er tatsächlich hat er
sich im märz dazu entschlossen nicht als
präsidentschaftskandidat der demokraten
ins rennen zu gehen und das lag daran
dass er das joe biden auch zu dieser
zeit ins rennen gegangen ist und diese
beiden männer verfolgen eine ähnliche
liberale politik haben eine ähnliche
agenda
und er wollte da die beiden wohl nicht
in die quere kommen jetzt aber
schwächelt joe biden das hat auch etwas
damit zu tun mit der ukraine affäre um
donald trump zu tun und blumberg scheint
auch niemand anderem in der
demokratischen partei zuzutrauen dass
sie gegen donald trump bestehen können
also entschuldigung also macht er ist
jetzt selbst weil er auch und das ist
noch ein punkt elizabeth warren nicht
zugestehen möchte dass sie die
spitzenreiterin bei den demokraten wird
denn sie gehört zum linken flügel und
blumberg ist konservativ also das möchte
möchte er eben auch nicht also macht es
erst selber er hat auch gute chancen er
hat eben 52 milliarden dollar im rücken
das ist eine menge geld und geld das
wissen wir im amerikanischen wahlkampf
ist ein wichtiger wenn nicht sogar
manchmal ein entscheidender
nun kann das aber möglicherweise auch
einen ungültigen geruchstest für ihn
geben dass er da einer ist der sack geld
kommt als wollte er sich den wahlsieg
kaufen werden dass die anderen sich
einfach gefallen das nein das haben sie
jetzt auch schon nicht getan also
bloomberg ist ja relativ spät in das
bewerberfeld reingekommen da haben
einige demo einige der kandidaten schon
etliche debatten auch hinter sich haben
sich ins zeug gelegt und da kommt jetzt
einer mit einem sack voll geld mit 52
milliarden und meint er könnte jetzt das
feld von hinten aufrollen es gab auch
schon unmut vor allem von den linken
elizabeth warren die wir gerade schon
angesprochen haben und auch bernie
sanders die sowieso immer mokieren das
geld die welt regiert beschweren sich
natürlich darüber und sagen man könnte
einen wahlkampf nicht kaufen
ob das bloomberg kümmert ich weiß es
nicht offenbar nicht denn er ist jetzt
aus auf ein duell der milliardäre
bloomberg gegen trump denn nur so glaubt
er könnte in den präsidenten aus dem
weißen haus jagen
das sind zwei männer ende 70 die da
politik machen wollen dankeschön
italiener zur deutschen politik da wird
die regierung nächste woche das
wichtigste gesetz von allen in den
bundestag bringen nämlich den haushalt
2020 das ist in zahlenkolonnen gepackt
knallharte politik geld es auch da nicht
alles aber ohne geld ist auch da alles
nichts die fetten jahre wissen wie er
wurde schon zig mal erklärt sind vorbei
es wird bald keine überschüsse für den
finanzminister mehr zu verteilen geben
davon wird aber der bedarf des landes
nicht kleiner
nur wird die frage laut ob es nicht doch
besser wäre dem staat auch bald wieder
mal das kredit aufnehmen schuldenmachen
zu erlauben
cornelia schiemenz berichtet marode
schulen die nicht saniert werden
tausende kilometer bahngleise die
stillgelegt wurden gegen den wo
telefonieren per handy glückssache und
schnelles mobiles internet ein fremdwort
ist
alles ist deutschland ein land das von
der substanz lebt 2,4 prozent seiner
wirtschaftsleistung gehen in den ausbau
der infrastruktur zu wenig sagen viele
experten zu wenig vor allem für die
digitale zukunft das hört der
finanzminister nicht gern
deutschland investiert vier wir haben
eine sehr expansive haushaltspolitik die
investitionen sind auf einem allzeithoch
das ist das ergebnis kluger
finanzpolitik aber schafft uns auch die
möglichkeiten die aufgaben der zukunft
zu bewältigen investitionen ja
neuverschuldung nein in diesem punkt
bleibt olaf scholz der politik seines
vorgängers im amt treu der
bundeshaushalt umfasst 362 milliarden
euro das sind 6 milliarden mehr als im
laufenden jahr ein plus von 1,6 prozent
gesetzt bleibt die schwarze null
es ist wichtig dass wir
haushaltssolidität behalten überhaupt
keine frage und jedes mal wenn
haushaltsspielräume sich auftun dann
sind die in der vergangenheit eben nicht
in investitionen hineingegangen nicht in
innovation nicht in zukunft sondern sind
in den umverteilungs bereichen
eingegangen und jeder der die schwarze
null jetzt infrage stellt der muss sich
dann fragen lassen ob das nicht zu
künftig auch sagen wir dass gesagt wird
jetzt haben wir ja geld und jetzt können
wir in denen und dem bereich wieder um
verteilen und das ist momentan der
falsche zeitpunkt dafür 17 stunden
marathon sitzung der bundestags experten
dann steht der haushalt 2020 den größten
teil 150 milliarden euro gibt der bund
für soziales aus für renten für hartz4
für soziale sicherheiten 45 milliarden
euro umfasst der verteidigungsetat 18
milliarden gehen in bildung und
forschung ein neuer rekordwert und 7
milliarden euro fließen in einen energie
und klima form
ich bin mit dem haushalt unzufrieden
weil es ein haushalt der kraftlos bei
investitionen ist und der
verantwortungslos ist was den
verteidigungsetat betrifft kritik die in
seltener übereinkunft auch von
wirtschaft und gewerkschaften geteilt
wird sie fordern ein milliardenschweres
ausgabenprogramm finanziert über neue
schulden
doch noch stellt sich die regierung zu
der bundestag beschließt in der
kommenden woche den haushalt die
schwarze null bleibt
professor marcel vater ist der präsident
des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung guten abend nach
berlin
guten abend herr fischer sie sind kein
freund der schwarzen null sie wollen dem
staat neue schulden erlauben ihn sogar
ermuntert sind sie nicht ein geradezu
und solider typ damit nein überhaupt
nicht denn wir müssen weg von der
mentalität dass schulden immer unbedingt
schlecht sind und sparen immer gut sind
denn wir haben es ja auch eben im
beitrag gehört der deutsche staat lebt
von seiner substanz ja ist es eine
schwarze null da aber auf der anderen
seite nimmt der wert der öffentlichen
infrastruktur von straßen brücken von
gebäuden von schulen
das verliert an wert und viel wichtiger
noch wenn man wirklich eine kluge
zukunftspolitik machen will dann muss
man doch überlegen was sind denn an
öffentlichen investitionen notwendig in
digitale netze im bereich innovation und
hier sehen wir hat deutschen eine
riesige lücke und riesigen bedarf und er
wird auch mit diesem haushalt nicht
gefüllt werden können aber das ist immer
das leichteste für die politiker
schulden zu machen da müssen wir keine
leistungen einschränken dass es ja immer
unpopulär und das ergebnis unterm strich
ist dass junge leute die jetzt ins
berufsleben gehen und anfangen ernsthaft
steuern zu zahlen
die sind miteigentümer von fast 2000
milliarden schulden des deutschen
staates wie kann man da
verantwortungsbewusst noch mehr drauf
häufen er ist immer die frage wofür das
geld ausgegeben wird und sie haben
absolut recht schulden müssen für einen
künftigen generationen bezahlt werden
aber zukunftsinvestitionen in digitalen
netze so das unternehmen eine digitale
transformation machen können ist ja auch
im interesse der künftigen generationen
wir haben eine riesige herausforderung
der deutschen wirtschaft viele
mittelständische unternehmen müssten
eine digitale transformation machen um
im globalen wettbewerb mithalten zu
können
und das sind die jobs der zukunft also
eine kluge zukunftspolitik erfordert
weniger im bereich beispielsweise konsum
konsumausgaben sozialausgaben mehr im
bereich investition denn das ist
letztlich auch dazu gehöre die guitar
infrastruktur aber auch klimaschutz das
ist ja gerade im interesse der künftigen
generation also man muss nur 1000 jahren
wird der staat immer gute möglichkeiten
finden geld auszugeben und das wird
immer überzeugend klingen und das wird
immer einfacher
sein seien neue schulden zu machen als
zu sagen okay jetzt müssen wir an ein
paar ausgaben malern subventionen oder
sozialleistungen oder so das wird weh
tun
ich werde vielleicht weniger stimmen
kriegen aber bevor ich neue schulden
mache mache ich lieber das und das hört
man halt relativ seiten ja da gebe ich
ihnen recht es wird immer darüber
gesprochen wo soll das geld ausgegeben
werden dass wir zu wenig überlegt wo
kann auch mal geld eingespart werden
effizienter geld ausgegeben werden und
wir haben wir wissen gerade im
sozialbereich 100 milliarden euro wird
allein für die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung ausgegeben das sind
auch die zukünftigen generationen die
das zahlen müssen
also man muss sehr genau überlegen wie
belasse man künftige generation und die
schuldenbremse ist ja prinzipiell auch
gut zu sein der staat darf sich nicht
zusätzlich verschulden aber was in
dieser logik viel ist zu sagen der staat
darf aber auch nicht von seiner substanz
leben und auf kosten künftiger
generationen also man braucht eine
balance zwischen begrenzung von schulden
und der stärkung von investitionen diese
balance ist im augenblick so mit der
schuldenbremse wie sie gegeben ist eben
nicht vorhanden
die wissenschaftler die es ja auch gibt
die anderer ansicht sind als sie die
politiker die meinen dass man das nicht
machen soll
sie sagen jemand wie fratzscher der
macht mit der abschaffung der schwarzen
null jetzt wieder das türchen zu diesem
ganz bequemen weg des schuldenmachens
auf und dann das haben wir immer wieder
gelernt ist kein halten mehr und
irgendwann werden die zinsen auf diese
schulden steigen und dann ist es nicht
mehr lust naja die schwarze null ist ja
kein selbstzweck kleber sondern man
macht ja eine schwarze null in guten
zeiten und sie haben es eben beschrieben
wir haben fette jahre hinter uns wo die
schwarze null absolut richtig war
damit man in schwierigen zeiten
spielraum hat und deutschland ist heute
in einer wirtschaftlich schwierigen lage
wir haben mit das geringste wachstum in
ganz europa es gibt ein drag city kommen
wird es gibt globale handelskonflikt es
gibt probleme in der euro zone also die
nächsten jahre könnten auch sehr hart
für deutschland werden und da als
politik klug zu reagieren und zu sagen
wir müssen auch die politik hat eine
aufgabe die wirtschaft zu stabilisieren
private investitionen zu unterstützen
das ist glaube ich die die essenz also
eine kluge balance ja schulden müssen
begrenzt sein
der staat muss sein geld auch wirklich
effizienter und klüger ausgeben
aber gleichzeitig dürften die
investitionen eben nicht immer hinten
runter fallen so wie das in den letzten
20 jahren der fall war
das ist eine debatte die jetzt am
dienstag glaube ich im haushalt des
bundestages geführt wird wir wollten
darauf vorbereiten danke für das
gespräch sehr gerne und wir wollen die
woche nicht beschließen ohne nochmal
nach großbritannien zu schauen
schließlich ist da eine menge los ein
wahlkampf über die richtung des landes
dicht zusammen gepresst in wenigen
wochen nur noch zweieinhalb bis 12
dezember aber dass viele diese woche
alles tief in den hintergrund als sich
prinz andrew mit einem schier
unfassbaren interview um würde und de
facto auch ums prinzen amt brachte das
hatte den briten gerade noch gefehlt
eine erschütternde blamage des
königshauses wenn schon die bürgerliche
politik nichts mehr auf die reihe
bekommt ein zustandsbericht unserer
london korrespondentin und ihre diagnose
hier versagen in großbritannien auf
ganzer linie
die kerne glückliches königreich alle
drängen sich um einen platz an seiner
spitze
die luft markt dünn sein mangel an
bewerbern gibt es nicht und doch ein
personalproblem
die drei protagonisten der woche sind
männer in ihren besten jahren alle auf
privatschulen erzogen alle ohne talent
zur selbstkritik alle auf ihre art
unehrlich
die frage die die briten umtreibt ist
diese können wir ihnen trauen ja wie nur
einem premier der hauptsächlich deswegen
an den dragset glaubt weil der ihn zum
premier gemacht hat heute haben die
konservativen ihr wahlprogramm
präsentiert es verspricht mal wieder 1
dann lasst uns den brachse durchziehen
und es wird eine flut von investitionen
ins land kommen lasst uns den br- exit
durchziehen und wir können uns auf die
prioritäten der briten konzentrieren und
die liegen im gesundheitswesen neuen
wohnungen mehr polizisten
alles bereiche die die konservativen
neun jahre lang klein gespart haben nun
plötzlich ist geld für all das womit sie
jeremy corbijn wähler klauen können der
verscheucht seine anhänger derweil mit
macht selbst verweigert sich stellung zu
beziehen beim brennendsten thema der
nation premier werde ich eine neutrale
position zum exit einnehmen und dafür
sorgen dass unser land wieder
zusammenfindet doch die neutralität ist
keine noble position sie soll verdecken
dass er für den exit ist und seine
partei dagegen in diesem bild des
jammers leuchtet nur die queen als
tröstliches überbleibsel aus der zeit
als das königreich einem respekt
abverlangte wieder aber schießt ein
selbstverliebter ehrgeizling quer prinz
andrew war der queen liebster sohn
bisher ihren palast für ein interview
nutzte das dem wort fremdschämen neue
bedeutung gab andrew leugnet darin sex
mit einer 17 jährigen gehabt zu haben
die frau hatte ausgesagt er habe dabei
massiv geschwitzt
da gibt es ein kleines problem mit dem
schwitzen denn als ich im falklandkrieg
angeschossen wurde habe ich eine
überdosis adrenalin produziert und es
war mir damals sozusagen unmöglich zu
schwitzen mediziner sagen diese
erklärung sei unhaltbar
ein land das solche männer zu seinen
besten zählen muss braucht keine feinde
armes königreich mache ich nun von
gundula gause papst franziskus hat in
japan in beispielloser schärfe bau und
besitz von atomwaffen verurteilt der
einsatz von kernenergie zu kriegszwecken
sei ein verbrechen
heute mehr denn je sagte er in hiroshima
und nagasaki 1945 zehntausende durch
us-atombomben getötet wurden
eindrücklich forderte der papst
weltweite atomare abrüstung und
verurteilte rüstungsausgaben als eine
himmelschreiende vergeudung angesichts
weltweiter armut und klimaprobleme
bayern und baden württemberg steigen aus
dem geplanten nationalen bildungsrat aus
der die bildungspolitik in deutschland
einheitlich er machen sollte aus beiden
ländern ist zu hören dass sie eine
verschlechterung ihrer bildungssysteme
befürchten
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck
bedauerte die entscheidungen die nicht
überraschend sein
nun müssten die länder beraten wie sie
weiter vorgehen wollen im irak sind bei
protesten gegen die regierung mehrere
menschen getötet worden
im süden des landes eröffneten
sicherheitskräfte das feuer gegen
demonstranten mindestens drei kam jungs
auch in anderen städten wurde scharfe
munition und tränengas eingesetzt
die proteste waren anfang oktober
ausgebrochen 300 menschen verloren
bislang ihr leben im süden frankreichs
haben heftige unwetter und
überschwemmungen zwei menschen das leben
gekostet
ganze landstriche wurden überflutet
zahlreiche straßen sind unpassierbar
auch in italien regnet es seit tagen
heftig viele bewohner sind nach
erdrutschen von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten
zwischen turin und zur wohnung wurde
eine 30 meter hohe autobahnbrücke von
schlammmassen weggerissen
verletzt wurde dabei niemand in hongkong
war heute ein ungewöhnlicher tag ohne
gewalt ohne proteste und auch ohne
machtdemonstrationen der staatsgewalt
man nämlich wahltag ist offiziell geht
es nur um die bezirksräte der stadtteile
das ist keine große das ist ganz kleine
politik und trotzdem ist es eine
schicksalswahl weil es um die reste von
demokratie und selbstbestimmung
gegenüber china geht die hongkongs
bürger verteidigen wollen entscheidend
ist deshalb die wahlbeteiligung und die
war groß demonstrativ groß ulf röller
ist für uns in hongkong und noch gibt es
keine ergebnisse aber es gibt einen
trend ihr seht ihr aus also sind
eigentlich jetzt schon fast die hälfte
der bezirke ausgezählt und danach ist
sehr klar es ist ein erdrutsch artiger
sieg für die demokratischen kräfte für
diese demokratie bewegung die sich ganz
bewusst diese wahl zu einer abstimmung
gemacht hat ob man die
demonstrationsbewegung weiter
unterstützen will oder nicht und
hongkongs bürger haben sehr klar gesagt
sie wollen dass trotz vielleicht mancher
großer gewaltexzesse die es gegeben hat
man muss ja wissen den letzten wochen
hatten eigentlich hongkongs bürger keine
chance mehr friedlich auf die straße zu
gehen weil keine demonstration genehmigt
wurde und diese gewalt geht an
stattgefunden hat drohte ein bisschen
die bewegung die seele aufzufressen
und nun gab es die gelegenheit bei
dieser wahl laut zu sprechen und
hongkongs bürger haben wohl sehr sehr
laut gesprochen und sagen sie
unterstützen die
demonstranten und sie wollen die
demokratie bewahren wird das denn
wirkung zeigen auf china in letzter zeit
hat er die lage sich immer gefährlicher
zugespitzt das ist sehr sehr schwer zu
beantworten also die demonstranten und
die bezirksabgeordnete jetzt gewählt
worden sind die hoffen dass mit diesem
wahlsieg vielleicht die regierung auf
sie zugeht und vielleicht ein oder zwei
forderungen erfüllt zb dass die
polizeigewalt aus ihrer sicht von einer
unabhängigen kommission untersucht wird
und dass die leute die festgenommen
worden sind nicht als aufrührer
angeklagt werden weil da steht eine
haftstrafe von zehn jahren
ob das wirklich passiert ob das die
regierung macht das weiß keiner
das schlimmste was passieren könnte ist
eigentlich dass die regierungschefin die
sich ja nur peking verpflichtet fühlt
carril m eben gar nichts macht sie hat
ja auch nichts gemacht als zwei
millionen menschen friedlich auf die
straße ging und einfach hart bleibt und
das hieß dann wahrscheinlich auch das
wieder sehr sehr schwierige tage vor
hongkong stehen eben auch tage der
gewalt dankeschön ulf die demokraten
haben jedenfalls gemacht was sie tun
konnten sie haben gewählt
weitere hintergründe zur lage in
hongkong finden sie auch online auf
heute.de ebenso die wichtigsten fragen
und antworten zu den wahlen heute
rumänien sorgen land der europäischen
union wählt heute seinen präsidenten neu
man könnte meinen da seien gut und böse
sauber getrennt gut das wäre der
aktuelle präsident klaus johannes der
aus dem deutschsprachigen siebenbürgen
stammt ein saubermann mit reformer image
pro europäer den muss man doch von hier
aus gesehen vorziehen wenn die
konkurrentin veolia dann schüler so
genannte sozialdemokraten als marionette
des ehemaligen parteivorsitzenden der
wegen korruption hinter gittern ist aber
so einfach nach der papierform ist das
nicht zu beurteilen
britta hilpert berichtet es gibt noch
kein ergebnis aber es sieht nach einem
großen sieg für hannes aus das heißt
aber noch lange nicht dass alles gut
wird in rumänien denn papierform zählt
nicht auf dem papier
haben ja auch alle rumänen anspruch auf
medizinische behandlung zum beispiel
kostenlos von der wiege bis zur bahre
begleitet rumänen die korruption
der kleine dank in die tasche der
hebamme das geldbündel für bessere
behandlungen bei razzien fliegen
regelmäßig nur die kleinen fische auf
die großen kommen meistens davon
dagegen gingen in rumänien immer wieder
tausende auf die straße auch weil
spitzenpolitikern korruption
nachgewiesen wurde
es war ein erster großer erfolg dieser
bewegung dass darüber die regierung der
sozialdemokratischen partei von bio rica
dann schien
stattdessen wollte sie präsidentin
werden und so wurde korruption zu dem
thema dieser präsidentschaftswahl das
korruptionsproblem ist mir sehr wichtig
das ganze land leidet darunter
das war das bestimmende thema schon in
der ersten runde haben ja die meisten
für den kandidaten bestimmt der gegen
korruption blüht die korruption und am
johann es sind eine menge leute die
gegen korruption kämpfen aber es gibt
faule äpfel in jedem korb oder verrostet
durch der konservative amtsinhaber klaus
johannis war der favorit und gewann
deutlich denn er hat die sehnsucht der
rumänen zu seinem wahlslogan gemacht ich
persönlich habe gestimmt für ein
modernes europäisches und normales
erfolgreich profilierte sich johannes
als politischer saubermann
doch auch in seiner partei gibt es
fragezeichen auf wahlkampf im norden zum
beispiel zeigte er sich mit dem partei
granden und landesfürsten flut uhr
genannt der holz baron
indessen region regiert die johannes
partei seit vielen jahren und hier hat
der wald noch mehr lücken als sonst
schon in rumänien das illegale abholzen
der sogenannten holzmafia ist eine
nationale plage
so erzählt es nicht nur dieser insider
und das geht nur weil die mafia von oben
gedeckt wird was sie behörden und
politik in der tasche hat sie sind die
das abholzen zu lassen sie kontrollieren
die sogenannte checks und so geht das
weiter so lange der holzbau und flut an
der macht ist das war heute auch eine
richtungswahl meinen viele für ein
besseres saubereres rumänien johannes
selbst mag nicht korrupt sein und es
ehrlich meinen mit dem kampf gegen
korruption
aber es geht dabei nicht nur um den
politischen gegner
es geht um das ganze land und auch seine
eigene partei und es gab außer politik
noch was wettbewerbs ähnliches sport an
diesem sonntag in der fußball bundesliga
hat mainz 05 am abend unter leitung
seines neuen trainers achim beierlorzer
einen beeindruckenden auswärtssieg
erzielt 5 zu 1 bei der tsg hoffenheim
und das in einer halbzeit in unterzahl
die 05 er damit auf platz 13 der tabelle
direkt hinter dem fc augsburg wird zuvor
hertha bsc klar besiegt hatte 40
die wintersportsaison hat begonnen für
die deutschen rodler war der auftakt
beim weltcup in innsbruck excel
durchwachsen einen von drei dritten
plätzen holte die mixed-staffeln julia
taubes felix loch sowie toni eggert und
sascha benecken konnten sich trotz
einiger schwächen noch bronze sichern
jubel beim team italien über platz 1
silber ging an österreich einen
fehlstart in die neue skisprung saison
hat weltmeister markus eisenbichler
erlebt im polnischen wisla landete er
bei türkischen windbedingungen auf dem
fünfzigsten und damit letzten platz
bester deutscher war karl geiger auf
platz 7 gewonnen hat den ersten einzel
weltcup der saison der norweger tander
und skirennfahrer linus strasser
hat beim weltcup im finnischen levi rang
acht belegt das zweitbeste slalom
ergebnis seiner weltcup karriere den
sieg holte der norweger christopher sind
nachrichten sind nicht planbar
das haben wir diese woche wieder
festgestellt dass das duell märz kramp
karrenbauer für das erste mal sich in
wohlgefallen auflöst das konnte man
vorher nicht wissen und dass ein new
yorker multi-milliardär anders als tramp
ein unzweifelhaft mega reicher mann in
den wahlkampf gegen kramm zieht kann
schon bald wieder eine vergessene
anekdote seien im moment spricht einiges
dafür dass blumberg die lage verändern
kann aber beweis
mit dieser vorwarnung unser kurzer blick
auf absehbares nächste woche
[Musik]
von der leyen auf der zielgeraden am
mittwoch stimmt das eu parlament über
die neue kommission ab geht alles glatt
kann ursula von der leyen am ersten
dezember mit ihrem team der neuen eu
regierung starten
einen monat später als geplant und ohne
einen kommissar aus großbritannien wenn
er mittwoch die mehrheit steht kann es
losgehen
auch die spd hat es fast geschafft bis
zum freitag dürfen die spd ja in einer
stichwahl noch ihre neue parteispitze
wählen wird es das duo ass keen walter
borjans oder doch gewiss scholz am
samstag gibt das ergebnis hochoffiziell
und eine woche später auf dem parteitag
dann wohl die endgültige bestätigung
mancher denkt endlich 100 jahre
friedrichstadtpalast
es ist ein haus deutscher geschichte hat
die goldenen zwanziger geprägt die nazis
einigermaßen überlebt und die sed auch
1980 wurde das große schauspielhaus wie
es ganz früher hieß abgerissen vier
jahre später wieder eröffnet so sieht es
heute aus man feiert dort immer noch
jetzt 100 jähriges na dann
hoch die beine und das wetter bleibt in
dieser letzten novemberwoche grauen
teilweise neblig und trüb
so startet auch der montag durchwachsen
meist bleibt es bedeckt oder neblig
trübe bei fünf bis zehn grad und auch
danach gibt es viele wolken und nur
wenig sonne
dazu fällt häufiger regen bei weiterhin
milden temperaturen
das muss alles jetzt nicht heißen dass
die nachrichten bocket trüb und grau
oder milde wird im gegenteil
marietta slomka ist hier mit heinz wolf
eine gute zeit auf wiedersehen
[Musik]